according to Media leaks Joe Biden he's
going to get off scott free listen to
this on the classified document case
that is now about to come to a close Joe
Biden's own doj will not charge him with
anything apparently that's not a
surprise we know that they have been
politicized and weaponized uh but guess
why because his name is not Trump it's
not you know a conservative sad now
although we're told that the special
counsil is preparing to give Joe a very
Stern talk to sure that's going to
bother Joe because he doesn't even know
what day it is as we have long known
when your last name is Biden when your
last name is Clinton you're a Democrat
you're running for re-election in
Biden's case the rules simply do not
apply to you keep in mind Biden
mishandled classified documents
materials for decades some of the
documents that were recovered were
apparently smuggled out of Capitol Hill
from his time as a US senator in the
early 2000s investigators found
sensitive material in many locations
including Biden's personal library in
Delaware you know stashed next to his
Corvette in his garage that's open all
the time the same house where Hunter
lived and worked uh off and on selling
the quote Biden brand to America's top
geopolitical foes while in the throws of
addiction with no experience at all so
needless to say those documents were not
safe they were not secure but there's no
punishment classified documents were
also retrieved from the Penn Biden
Center in Washington DC now that Center
was founded after many very generous
Financial gifts you got it to upen from
China and other sensitive material from
Biden's long career in government was
retrieved during a search at Biden's
beach house he only lived off a you know
Senator salary right he can everybody
can afford a beach house and of course
another search at the Biden Biden
archives that's at the University of
Delaware now of course because we're
talking about Biden and not about Trump
none of these discoveries were made
during a surprise early morning raid no
instead Biden's doj very politely
negotiated what was a search of these
properties with Biden's legal team
giving Joe plenty of warning before each
visit now we saw the same thing with
Hillary Clinton in 2016 her home it was
never raid by the FBI those 33,000
emails with classified secret material
on them you know the ones on unsecure
servers private servers of hers that we
believe were hacked by our enemies uh
before Clinton then of course destroyed
33,000 emails we' never heard of bleach
pit before but that's when you acid wash
your hard drives and your servers clean
we never heard about AIDS that's right
they took hammers to blackberries and
iPhones SIM cards were removed hm where
I grew up that might be called
obstruction of justice and despite this
mountain of evidence that Hillary
Clinton mishandled all of this top
secret material and obstructed Justice
well James Comey the FBI director at the
time said no reasonable prosecutor would
ever prosecute a case against a
democratic nominee for president this is
important it is relevant take a look
from the group of 30,000 emails returned
to the state department in
2014 110 emails in 52 email chains have
been determined by the owning agency to
contain classified information at the
time they were sent or received eight of
those chains contained information that
was Top Secret at the time they were
sent 36 of those chains contained secret
information at the time and eight
contained confidential information at
the time although there is evidence of
potential violations of the statutes
regarding the handling of classified
information our judgment is that no
reasonable prosecutor would bring such a
case this is a dual justice system again
if you're a Democrat you mishandle
classified documents well you just get a
stern lecture if that if you're Donald
Trump you get your house turned upside
down and more than what three dozen uh
stacked felony charges designed to put
you in prison for the rest of your life
but unfortunately for Biden well his
legal woses are not over despite the
doj's best efforts House and Senate
Republicans now have uncovered a paper
trail that is a mile long that shows the
entire Biden family Syndicate and their
addiction to foreign cash we're talking
about tens of millions of dollars Equity
uh lavish gifts other funds uh oh let's
see loans with no interest rates that
are forgivable all this money passed
through shell corporations identified by
James comr uh from foreign countries
let's see China Russia Ukraine
Kazakhstan Romania and these are among
the most corrupt countries in the entire
world and they were all sending money to
the Biden family but here's the question
why what did they do for that money the
bidens were providing that we all we can
see is little in return pretends of
millions of dollars other than of course
they got access to the big guy and
coincidentally Enough by the way the
family finances were very much
co-mingled with Hunter allegedly paying
pops bills complaining about having to
half of his income to pops uh and of
course James Biden cutting huge checks
to Joe Biden it all reeks of nothing but
public corruption that's why we call it
the Joe Biden bribery and money
laundering Scandal allegations so given
the egregious nature of these Shady
Financial practices and the tarnished
reputation of Biden's weaponized and
politicized doj well the justice
department they may just be looking for
a sacrificial lamb and according to even
fake news CNN the special counsel has
now impanel the grand jury as part of
their investigation into zero experience
Hunter and they're now seeking documents
and testimony from multiple Witnesses
including Joe Biden's brother James
remember Joe Biden said to us as a
candidate he said it as a president I
never once talked to my son Hunter my
brother or anybody for that matter about
their foreign business deals and
meanwhile House Republicans they are
seeking an interview with Hunter
so-called sugar brother guy by the name
ofev Morris who always seems to rescue
Hunter whenever he needs a few million
dollars here a few million dollars there
to pay his taxes or other bills or he
needs a new car now tonight I don't know
if Hunter is going to actually be thrown
under the bus by his father's doj but I
am certain of this that the big guy will
never face a single charge as long as we
have a corrupt Department of Justice led
by a corrupt AG by the name of Merck
Garland who's now running the show at
the doj and of course we know their
hatred for Donald Trump it runs deep
this is the sad nature of America's
justice system today it has been
politicized it has been weaponized hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else